Pergunta que eu recebi aqui. Suplementos
de vitamina C com 500 mg a 1 g por
cápsula podem ser tomados todos os dias?
É uma pergunta que muitas pessoas fazem.
Sabe quando você pega aquele frasco de
vitamina C na farmácia? Será que eu
posso tomar isso todo dia? Pois é, meu
amigo, minha amiga, hoje vamos bater um
papo reto sobre esse assunto que gera
polêmica. E olha, eu já vou adiantar uma
coisa para você. A resposta não é tão
simples quanto o sim ou não, mas eu vou
te contar tudo que você precisa saber
para tomar uma decisão bem informada.
Imagine só, nosso corpo é tipo aquele
carro importado que precisa de
combustível premium para funcionar
direito. A vitamina C é o famoso ácido
ascóbico, é um desses combustíveis
especiais. Diferente de outros animais,
nós humanos perdemos a capacidade de
produzir a nossa própria vitamina C lá
atrás na evolução. Então, cara,
dependemos totalmente do que comemos ou
suplementamos. É como se a natureza
tivesse tirado nossa fábrica interna e
agora precisamos buscar fora. Agora vem
a parte interessante. As recomendações
oficiais dizem que homens adultos
precisariam de 90 mg por dia e mulheres
de 75 mg. Mas aí que tá o pulo do gato.
Essas doses foram calculadas basicamente
para evitar uma doença da época da
navegação, o escorbuto, aquela doença
dos marinheiros antigos que ficavam sem
frutas frescas em viagem de meses. É
tipo dizer que você precisa de x L de
água só para não morrer de sede, mas
para ficar hidratado de verdade e
performar bem, a conversa é outra.
Quando falamos de dose entre 500 mg e 1
g por dia, estamos entrando em outro
território bem diferente. A medicina
funcional, a medicina ortomolecular,
trabalha com conceito de dose ótima e
não de dose mínima. É a diferença entre
sobreviver e prosperar, ok? Essas doses
mais robustas visam só prevenir
deficiências, mas otimizar funcionamento
do organismo. É como turbinar o motor do
carro em vez de só mantê-lo funcionando
no básico. O bacana é que a vitamina C é
hidrossolúvel, ou seja, ela se dissolve
em água. Isso significa que o excesso
vai embora pela urina, pelo xixi. O seu
corpo é bem esperto, pega o que for
preciso e manda o resto para fora. Por
isso que é bem seguro tomar essas doses
de 500 a 1 g diariamente. O limite
máximo tolerável estabelecido seria de 2
g por dia. Acima disso, algumas pessoas
podem ter desconforto gástrico ou aquela
diarreia chata, mas entre 500 mg e 1 g é
uma faixa super tranquila. Lembrando que
doses muito altas de vitamina C pode
funcionar muito bem para várias
situações específicas, mas não é o
motivo desse vídeo. Deixa eu te contar
uma coisa que poucos sabem. Absorção da
vitamina C tem os seus truques. Quando
você toma 100 mg, o corpo absorve quase
90%. Mas conforme a dose aumenta, a
porcentagem de absorção diminui. É como
se o corpo tivesse um limite de quanto
consegue processar por vez. Por isso,
alguns especialistas em medicina
integrativa recomendam dividir a dose ao
longo do dia, tipo 500 mg de manhã, 500
mg à tarde, em vez de 1 g de uma vez só.
E os benefícios, a lista é grande.
Estamos falando de antioxidante poderoso
que combate radicais livres, aqueles
vilões que aceleram o envelhecimento e
causam uma monte de problemas.
A vitamina C turbina o sistema
imunológico, ajuda na produção de
colágeno para manter a sua pele firme e
suas articulações saudáveis, melhora a
absorção de ferro, acelera a
cicatrização, ainda tem ação
antiinflamatória. É tipo um canivete
suíço. Na medicina automolecular, que é
onde a coisa fica ainda mais
interessante, trabalha-se com o conceito
de individualidade bioquímica. Cada
pessoa tem necessidades diferentes,
dependendo do estilo de vida, nível de
estresse, exposição a toxinas, prática
de exercícios. Um fumante, por exemplo,
precisaria de muito mais vitamina C que
um não fumante. Quem vive estressado
também queima mais vitamina C. É como se
cada situação aumentasse o consumo do
seu tanque de combustível. Tem gente que
me pergunta: "Mas, doutor, não é melhor
tu pegar a vitamina C dos alimentos?"
Claro que uma dieta rica em frutas e
vegetais é fundamental. laranja, kiwi,
acerola, pimentão, brócolis, tudo isso é
maravilhoso. Mas vamos combinar que no
corre do dia a dia, nem sempre as
pessoas se lembram ou conseguem comer a
quantidade ideal. E mesmo comendo bem,
às vezes precisamos daquele reforço
extra, especialmente em períodos de
maior demanda do nosso organismo. Ou em
situações específicas, por exemplo, uma
gripe, uma virose, você pode precisar de
doses altas de vitamina C por um período
curto de tempo. Um detalhe importante
sobre o horário, não existe melhor hora
para tomar a vitamina C. Pode ser de
manhã, à tarde, à noite, com sem comida.
Agora, se você tem um estômago mais
sensível, tomar junto com as refeições
pode ajudar a evitar qualquer
desconforto. É questão de conhecer o seu
corpo e ajustar conforme a sua
necessidade. E sabe o que que é mais
legal? Estudos recentes mostram que
doses maiores de vitamina C podem ter
benefícios que vão além da prevenção de
gripes e resfriados. Estamos falando de
potencial neuroprotetor, melhora de
função cognitiva, suporte na produção de
neurotransmissores, com a dopamina que
influenciam o nosso humor e nosso
bem-estar. É como se a vitamina C fosse
um investimento na sua saúde cerebral
também. Agora vamos falar de qualidade.
Nem toda a vitamina C é igual. Tem a
versão básica, o ácido ascóbico puro e
tem versões mais sofisticadas como o
ascobato de sódio ou cálcio, que são
versões menos, são versões em que foi
feito o uso do tampão, então são mais
gentis com estômago. Tem também a
vitamina C lipossomal que vem
encapsulada em gorduras e tem absorção
melhorada. É como escolher entre ser um
carro popular e um sedã executivo. Os
dois vão te levar ao destino, mas a
experiência pode ser diferente. Na
prática clínica da medicina funcional,
muitos profissionais trabalham com
protocolos personalizados. Alguns
pacientes se beneficiam de 500 mg,
outros precisam de 1 g ou até em
situações específicas doses muito
maiores do que isso. O importante é
entender que não existe uma dose única
que serve para todo mundo. É tipo roupa.
Tem gente que veste P, outros vestem em
GG. E tá tudo certo. Uma coisa que
precisa ficar clara, suplementar com 500
mg a 1 g de vitamina C por dia é
considerado seguro paraa vasta maioria
das pessoas saudáveis. Você não vai ter
hipervitaminose C porque, como eu já
falei, o excesso vai embora pela urina.
O máximo que pode acontecer com doses
nessa faixa é o vxixi ficar mais
amarelinho. Em pessoas muito sensíveis,
talvez um pouquinho de desconforto
gástrico que geralmente melhora tomando
com alimentos. Para finalizar o nosso
papo, deixa eu te dar o resumo da ópera.
Sim, você pode tomar suplementos de
vitamina C de 0,5 a 1 g diariamente com
segurança. Essa dose está bem dentro dos
limites seguros, oferece benefícios que
vão além da prevenção básica de
deficiências e pode ser uma ferramenta
valiosa na sua estratégia de saúde
preventiva e otimização do bem-estar
geral.
O segredo é escolher um produto de
qualidade, prestar atenção em como seu
corpo responde e ajustar conforme
necessário. E lembre-se, suplementação é
isso aí. Um suplemento não um substituto
para uma alimentação equilibrada e um
estilo de vida saudável. É a cereja do
bolo, não o bolo inteiro, tá entendendo?
Então é isso, meu amigo. Espero que
agora você se sinta mais seguro para
tomar aquela decisão sobre sua
suplementação de vitamina C. E se você
já toma, continue firme. Seu corpo
agradece esse cuidado extra que você tá
tendo com você. Afinal, investir em
prevenção é sempre mais inteligente que
remediar depois, não é mesmo? Yeah.